أعتقد أنه من المهم إدانة ذلك
ما نراه في فلسطين هو
الإبادة الجماعية أعتقد أنها كذلك
من المهم أن نسمي الأشياء بأسمائها الحقيقية
اسم هناك الآلاف من الصحابة
من الأطفال العاجزين الذين فقدوا
أجزاء من جسده إلى العشرات
أفراد عائلاتهم، ماذا سنفعل بهم؟
يقول الصحابة لهؤلاء
الأطفال عندما يكونون غدًا
الكبار كيف سنسأل هؤلاء
الناس الذين يؤمنون بالديمقراطية
نؤمن بالشرعية الدولية التي
نؤمن بالأمم المتحدة عندما تكون في
أحلك لحظة الجميع
لقد أدار ظهره ولكنني أتساءل
أكثر ماذا سنقول لدينا
أبنائنا وبناتنا كيف
يمكننا أن نشرح لأطفالنا و
بناتنا الذين قصفوا الآلاف من
الأبرياء ولم نفعل شيئا
الزملاء والزملاء يعودون إلى ماذا
العودة الهامة الأساسية إلى ماذا
أخلاقيا لا يمكننا تحمل هائلة
التناقض في المطالبة بفلسطين
يتم الالتزام بالقانون الدولي
عندما لا نكون قادرين حتى على ذلك
قطع العلاقات الدبلوماسية مع
نتنياهو وتقديمه أمام محكمة الجنايات
الدولية ليتم الحكم عليها
ما هو مجرم
حرب